how did you get red pill by the way
well like was it a girl was it uh no
appointment like was it just a sequence
of events
no you know like what brought you to
roller stuff and seeing my stuff
well i've been single since college yeah
and i i've
you know you want to turn use the term
spinning plates or whatever
you know uh and and even prior to that
even when i was in grade school and in
high school i i
that was never a problem for me as far
as we'll say getting a date
right you know that's never really an
issue
and then uh i i played a lot of sports
and i was athletic
and uh i just um you know it's just
let's
just leave it at that it was never an
issue okay and then i started to make uh
quite a bit of money and uh so then it
became even easier
uh than it was before and before it was
very very how old were you when you made
your first million
i was a self-made millionaire at 34.
cool
and so uh and you're how old now
48. oh you're almost the same age
as me man
you're like you're exactly the same age
as me
yeah so uh i i
so it was never an issue and um
what was fascinating this one must have
been 2007 or something like that i never
watched tv but i stumbled across mystery
show remember no well
his show first i stumbled across his
show remember uh
the one where he walked around the
platforms with the painted fingernails
and the big hat and all that yeah and
he'd show the
the the the nerdy kids you know what
they're doing wrong and stuff what the
heck was it called
the lovable loser or something i don't
know
but anyway i saw that show that he had
on vh1
and i was immediately uh interested by
you know i'm like well this is kind of a
fascinating concept
and and then i i started to listen to
the psychology
behind what he was talking about and i'm
like wait a minute
this this makes sense because this
aligns with all of the experience
i have had with women up to that point
and not just me
but my buddies in college you know
you've got somebody's in college that's
weird
brad pitt you know it's like the code in
the matrix like you see how everything
works
you know yeah instead of seeing like the
summary you see like the full equation
to get to the summary yeah and when i
saw what he was teaching
the the nerdy kids or whatever and you
know how
that that was all the guys that i knew
in college and in high school for that
matter
that just had women just flocked to them
just naturally
that's how they were that was just their
normal
personality you know when he was talking
about nagging or something like that or
it's just that was just the way they
naturally were they they came from
a mindset i don't know what's first the
chicken or the egg but they would come
from a mindset of
total abundance when it comes to women
uh and and instead of this scarcity
mindset and because they
always felt as though there was just uh
abundance and they always had an
abundance
when they were uh texting you know back
in the day paging or whatever
you know when they were talking to the
gals around them it really dates you
when you talk about
paging so for those of you that are
watching this that are in like the core
of my demographic that probably never
heard of pagers we used to carry around
these little boxes on our belt
and they would buzz with a number on top
of it and it was usually
you know somebody was calling you to
call you back at that number so they
could get you
or you could check your voicemail yeah
yeah yeah
yeah so so but what mystery was talking
about i'm like that's
all the guys that i know where this came
very easy
this is just how they are naturally so
it kind of went from a subconscious
thing to a conscious thing
and then he just kind of made it a
science but that's what really
uh fascinated me and then
but you know the key component that he
was missing is he
obviously tells you you know how to
interact uh
when you first meet a gal and that's
going to be beneficial if you don't know
what you're doing
um but then once you start to date the
gal
you know that's when you have to read
rolo stuff
because if you just have mysteries stuff
let's say if you just have game
without the red pill stuff you're you're
you're
you're still not getting it you're going
to screw up and cause problems
yeah you've never been married you said
you've never had a long-term
relationship so you've mostly been a
lifetime plate spinner i mean did you
ever get like
what stopped you from inviting a woman
into your life on a more intimate basis
i think there's a lot of things first
and foremost when i
uh got out of college
i i knew that that well you know you
don't have the conscious thought i was
just hardcore entrepreneur that's all i
wanted to do is make money
i i just really the did you have an icon
that you followed like somebody that
inspired you
what's that did you have an icon that
you followed like somebody that inspired
you to become an entrepreneur like i
want to be that guy
no no i just i wanted to make money
and i wanted to figure out ways to make
money and
um you know once i got my claws into
something
uh i i i've been like this my whole life
i get very ocd
yeah and so um it can be good it can be
bad but i i'd get into a business
and i just get tunnel vision where i
wouldn't date
i mean i you know i had go out with gals
here and there but i
i it wasn't even part of my conscious
thought
for a long period of time when i was
just hyper focused
on uh building a business as an example
so um you know i there's there's a lot
of things that go into it i've always
been very
independent um and you've always getting
in the way of that goal like they
distract you from it or take you away
from it or
well i think you can definitely uh allow
that to happen
where uh gals can be just i think from
99 percent of
guys out there they're a huge
distraction because they
allocate so much time and energy into
pursuing women
when if they would just take that same
time and energy into pursuing
their business or pursuing excellence
like you say the women would fall into
place see that's what guys don't
understand
they think that they actively have to
pursue women
and that's that's not the case if you
pursue other things and if you pursue
personal growth
and professional growth then that you
don't have to pursue the women they'll
pursue you
it's four words chase excellence not
women
yeah that's all you need to know i mean
if you can do that
well and you know when women start
coming into your life you know you don't
screw it up by being a total simp or
like a plugged in beta
um it's not hard and it's fun
yeah and the magic to what you just said
is is not only
if you're single but if you are in a
relationship
it's just as applicable if not more so
because there's a lot of guys with a lot
of money out there and i'm sure you see
a lot of them too that
have been very successful they've put a
dent in the universe they've built some
kind of world-class product or service
they've changed people's lives you know
things have improved and they
have a massive store of value of it with
aka money you know as a result of that
but they just like suck so bad with
women man like they've been through
multiple marriages they have just women
that they just bend the knee to
completely even though they're like
champions of their craft
i'm i'm not going to mention any names
but but you and i
both know uh people that i'm very very
good friends with
that would at that would admit that they
fall into that category to a great
degree
it happens to a lot of men man and i
would like i wish i could talk to more
of those guys right like i talked to a
lot of dudes but i
but those guys would have the biggest
effect because of what they do in their
lives with their businesses
yeah it's it's unbelievable that they
can um
be so uh i don't know if alpha's the
right word
in their business life yet be so beta
in their personal life yeah it's crazy
yeah i've never
used that that that is i think uh the
majority
of guys that are like you know because
the majority of
the guys have this um idea
of what women want and it's just
completely skewed
uh for whatever reason they they think
that
well women want you to just constantly
compliment them and
constantly buy them chocolates and roses
and constantly just
to defreeze them to every single
decision you make
and what they don't understand yeah is
that's that's not
that's not the way it works that's not
what they want
and i think even gals who are honest
you know if if you say hey would would
you want
a guy who behaves this way or this way
they'd say no no that other
if they're too sappy if they're too over
the top it's just a complete turn off
but it's not to say that you you have to
be a jerk or you have to be an
that that's that's
really in the scene guys take it too far
and then they
become a jerk you've got to be this even
uh
kind of right in the middle i think and
uh you know not to be cliche but if you
look at like a james bond type
figure how you know you're in control
you've you've maintained
a frame to use your term but at the same
time you're a gentleman when you're in
the presence of that gal
you're an extreme extreme gentleman but
you're you're calling the shots you know
and and you are
um someone that uh any woman
would look up to and actually respect
and i think women respect ambition and
uh they also respect a guy that's a
decision maker
um that is a leader of other men that
can solve
problems and uh that can
take control of a situation while at the
same time someone that's going to treat
them well
you know yeah and guys just give his
bond avatar for that i think you really
you know hit the nail on the head
because i because i've talked to a lot
of guys now privately that are
that are seasoned gentlemen and i think
the james bond avatar is probably the
best way to
accurately define that and you want to
aim for a target aim for that
it's not a bad target to aim for yeah
it's just
you're you're in control of you
you know what speaking of that target
you're in control but yet you're a
gentleman at the same time you're not
you're not a prick you're not arrogant
you know
you